patriot mail today relates to something
that is going on on the show Patriot
mail if nothing else is often timely and
I'll remind you what hatred mail is
between waving a Gadsden flag from a
highway overpass to drafting George
Zimmerman for a 2016 run wrap a tree it
has little time for anything else but
when that annoying little dweeb David
Pakman really pushes the liberal
envelope beyond what a god-fearing tea
bagger can bear there's hatred mail your
brief respite from the unending deluge
of liberal bias so yes indeed the hate
rates are very focused on the big
announcement that producer lewis would
be seeking warmer and less urban areas
of the world to live in and as a result
will be leaving the david pakman show
the hey tree 'it's very focused on this
a double a twofer today for hatred mail
for you on this topic here is the first
one David lost his [ __ ] Lewis got sick
of being forced to wear shirts with
David Pakman on it and the constant
smarmy sarcasm I'm surprised he hasn't
bitch-slapped Pakman yet I sure would
Boston's a small town maybe my dream
will come true David Pakman you're a
disingenuous Soros shilling stupid son
of a [ __ ] you know I don't have a
problem with most of that surprisingly
but Soros shilling what evidence of that
is there that's a that's a common
patriot phim isn't it oh they're
obsessed with it but we've never had any
connection to George Soros no no but
they think there's a funding connection
they always do I mean pretty much anyone
saying anything even remotely positive
about Hillary Clinton is funded by
George Soros there must be some rich Jew
funding us it doesn't matter who exactly
it is but that's that's a common theme
and here is the second Lewis related
hatred mail for today David how do you
feel about your boyfriend leaving you'll
be alone in your mom's garage I thought
David Pakman show was run from a studio
garage that's what David keeps saying
on the show and that Luis is his
boyfriend now maybe without Luis help
you will stop lying dirt on mr. Trump
let me be very clear there is enough
dirt on Trump that I don't need Luis to
find it for me just looking at oh I
don't know any website doing any
investigation into this campaign gives
us information on that so people very
very focused the hate reott ISM going in
the direction of the big Luis
announcement and I will mention we have
turned hatred mail into something to
help the show we have a coupon code hey
treat for tha t RI ot for zero which if
entered when you're signing up for
membership on david pakman.com gives you
a 40% discount off of membership for
life and for that louis we can all be
grateful to the hatreds thank you hey
tree it's wonderful terrific terrific